okay I guess we're all here that are
going to be here can you hear me okay
great okay thank you for coming
especially after the break I'm going to
be talking about genealogy will go from
language it's a hobby that my wife and I
have gotten sucked into it's a great way
to kill a weekend and just by wave over
the background I discovered that the
data that are typically collected when
you do genealogy can be exported to a
file called dead calm and I looked at
the structure and I said hey I can suck
this up into mathematica and I could do
fun stuff with it so that's what led to
this and it's gotten along to a point
where i can actually speak about it so
before we spend any more time on
background let's let's get into it and
i'll tell you some of the things I've
been doing okay so you all read the
abstract there's been a lot of interest
in genealogy recently there's a lot of
stuff on TV these days there's still
always the traditional way of doing
genealogy you know family trees to pass
down and the families and the family
bible or things like that or you get to
your reunion and somebody puts a big
piece of paper on the table and
everybody writes where they are on that
particular branch my family had one like
that about 25 years ago and they did
that I had completely forgotten a my dad
went down to the basement last year and
pulled out between the rafters this
great big piece of craft paper it was
about six feet long and 4 feet wide with
a huge family tree on it with everything
on it that they knew about the people
filled in the extra stuff that had
occurred that other people didn't know
and I that's been one of my resources
for working on my family tree and then
more recently there is a new
technologies coming along besides the
traditional record-keeping we now have
genial DNA data genomic data to help
with this it doesn't get you down
identifying you know that you're related
to this person and that person but it
identifies something longer term where
your ancestors came from throughout the
world different populations and things
like that
okay so why do it and Wolfram language
well I didn't want to reinvent things
like ancestry com or family tree maker
things like that and what I originally
wanted to do when I was doing the
geological work was I discovered that a
lot of my ancestors grandparents and
their brothers and sisters and things
like that we're living in similar
neighborhoods close to each other in the
city of buffalo new york and i was
wondering well did they get married
because they were geographically close
can I map them and I took a look at
trying to do some stuff with google maps
and I couldn't figure out their API and
it fell away and then I you know started
working with Wolfram language with it
and yes you can do that so that was the
original justification for trying to do
something quantitative with the data and
then I decided I also wanted to do
things that you couldn't do with the
typical software usually you work with
one tree a single tree and you can't
merge trees and that's a typical problem
with genealogists because when they're
working trying to work out a tree for a
client they'll have a main trunk of the
tree main trunk of the tree but then
there's another group of people that
they think might be related but they're
not sure so they work with them in a
separate tree and then they find the
link and they have to glue them together
and that's not always easy and the doing
the reverse taking trees apart is also
not easy you have to make a copy of the
tree and delete half the people from one
and the other half from the other and
that's not nice and one reason that I
wanted to do that is that traditionally
genealogists do not store information
about living people in trees for
protection of privacy so I had trees
that had you know my generation in it my
kids generation my grandkids generation
and I really didn't want that in
ancestry so I wrote something where I
could export you know you can already
export the tree into this kid come
format file I pulled that in a
mathematica I broke the tree apart and
then uploaded back the deceased portion
of the tree that I can work with and
then I keep the live
portion locally on my laptop as a gedcom
file and then what I want to work with
it I pull it up I import it work with it
add stuff to it export it delete it and
that way I don't leave any traces I hope
around that would compromise anybody's
personal information so the benefits
with the summarized functions that I
wrote because it you know you don't want
to just look at the raw data you want to
put it together in a cohesive fashion
sometimes it does help me identify
mistakes that I've got in my data
because I can see for example all the
residences or all the occupations where
somebody was and I can quickly spot
errors where things are out of line miss
type things like that then I can go back
to the original source and correct them
they're also the code that I wrote that
imports the data I have to do rigorous
QC on it because not all of the
information pointers within the data are
correct sometimes they it's supposed to
be a doubly connected tree in both
directions from individual to family and
family back to the individuals a lot of
times only one of them are present and
then sometimes you get people that
disappear from the tree because they
their connections to the family get lost
during some editing that the person was
doing and while the individual is
carried along in the file you never get
to see them in the tree on the in the
browser so we've discovered some people
that got lost that way so you know
that's been an advantage of doing it and
lastly the code that we have by using
the built-in graph functions in Wolfram
language I can handle things that are
called cousin marriages much better and
this is where you you get a grandparents
or you know that have children and then
they have children and those children
are cousins to each other and if they
get married then you formed a a loop
closed it's not strictly speaking a
cycle because this is a directed graph
but often times the commercial software
doesn't render that at all and an
ancestry for example which is where I
work they actually make two copies of
each person in that last Union and then
you're wondering you know mr. Smith and
mr. Smith & mrs. Smith & mrs. Smith
who's who and where do the kids go from
that Union and things like that it can
be a real mess so okay so okay a little
bit of graph theory quiz time I can you
see these pictures okay should I make it
a little bigger I think we can afford
that okay here's the family tree okay
we've got one individual here another
one and more descendants and more
descendants so what kind of what kind of
graph is this okay I think I heard
somebody say tree yeah it's a tree in
fact it's it's actually a directed tree
because it goes from one node to the
next in one direction so it's a directed
tree okay so here's another one a little
more complicated a little more realistic
okay we've got individuals that are the
boxes we've got marriages or unions
families here that he's dots between
them here's a person that had two
different spouses because he was widowed
here's a parent that is missing his
spouse but there are two children that
we have information on so this is this
is much more realistic so what kind of
graph is this okay here here it is
depicted with graph plot okay same
information it's a directed acyclic
graph okay and they're also bipartite
because when you include the families in
them the way I do here with these extra
little nodes okay you end up with the
families being in one class of vertices
and the individuals in the other class
and this is a characteristic of all
family trees that they are bar pipe not
bipartite directed acyclic graphs okay
the last one here here's one this is one
that has a cousin marriage in
okay so we've got some cousins here Mary
Arden and john shakespeare got married
to form this family here and william
shakespeare was one of their children so
what kind of graph is this okay again
it's a directed acyclic graph it's a
cyclic because of the edges there's
there's no way you can get from an
individual back to that individuals
ancestor so it's still a cyclic even
though it looks like there's a closed
loop in there it's also bipartite and
here is the example showing we've got
William Shakespeare here and we got
William Shakespeare over here we've got
show Nick Jones Shakespeare and his
sister and Joan Shakespeare here his
sister and Margaret and Margaret so it
gets really confusing as to knowing what
to do here so this is why I like doing
it with real graph software okay so what
does get calm exactly good calm is it's
an acronym for genealogical data
communication it was developed by the
church of the latter-day saints the
Mormons because they have a mandate to
work out the genealogies of their
members the members are responsible for
doing that and so they've got all this
infrastructure in place to do it and
what's really great they've got a
website called ancestry com which has
all not all but it has an enormous
amount of data that you can search and
use to validate the information in your
family trees such as the US census city
directories all kinds of things that you
can use so this file is actually it's a
grammar and each line looks like this
there's a level indicator and then a
delimiter and then you may have some
optional information or an external
reference plus the delimiter and then a
tag which is a key thing and then
possibly a value and then the end of the
line okay
so again it's just just four parts a
level a reference ID or a pointer
actually a tag and a line value okay the
delimiter zar space is the terminators
or new lines okay the level that's used
here at the very beginning is what
determines the hierarchy and the data
okay so here we have a simple tree you
probably know this this family Abraham
Lincoln his wife Mary and their four
sons and this is the corresponding
gedcom file for it okay and we can see
here we've got the levels here in red
we've got the external reference IDs
here in blue we've got the tags in green
and then we've got the values out here
in the magenta we can look at a single
individual entry in the trend in the
file here's one for the first individual
and we've got information about the
death and then okay so about the
individual we've got the death and the
birth and the gender okay and then in
the death because at level two now we've
got the date and the place and similarly
for birth we've got date in place gender
doesn't have any derivative information
the name doesn't have any derivative
information they have marked up the
surname with slashes so you can identify
that clearly which helps and then we
have a reference to the family for this
individual that this individual is a
member of family f1 okay and then we
have family information in the file as
well so here's family f1 and the husband
is p1 the wife is p6 there's a child p5
who was a natural child of both the
father and the mother and so on and then
we have information additional
information about this family about its
marriage with a date in a place as well
ok so there are hierarchies also as I
mentioned and in the individuals so
here's the individual p1 again Abraham
and here it is in the the linear
notation that they use in their file but
this is the tree structure the
hierarchical structure that actually
represents and this is why it's so easy
to get into Wolfram language and then
the same for families okay here's the
linear notation that they use and then
here because of the the levels we we see
the information level zero level one
level two okay and then all the tags
that are used there are lots of them
most of them are well defined in the
specification there are what are called
program to find tags as well they begin
with an underscore so you're not
restricted to just the standard set you
can extend it and that then lets one
represent any kind of hierarchical
information in this file format and in
fact there's a link down here for
example for different human you know
languages as well as computer languages
that have been stored in the get come
format so you can see how the different
languages evolved both human languages
and computer languages okay so decision
time I can't possibly fit in everything
that I could in this talk so do we want
to take a road to the left or to the
right we want to look at applications or
do you want to look at the
implementation aspects your choice
not in your head means what what's that
okay we'll jump to the implementation
first and then we'll come back and look
at the applications okay this is a
technology conference so we're allowed
to do this I'm being a madman bad
Mathemagician because I'm showing you
how i do my tricks the data that I store
the data as a set of Lists essentially
as down values of these symbols here in
the package and I also maintain a list
of all the family trees so that I know
how many of these lists that I have each
of these lists for example the person's
have our our list of individuals the
individuals themselves consists of a
pointer a reference back to the family
tree to which they belong and then their
properties families have a similar
structure okay properties are also
hierarchical they have a description
string and then a list of sub properties
and the sub properties have the same
structures property so it can just keep
going as needed okay and then the way
you find the connections in an
individual there are pointers back to
the family where the person is a child
in the family and there are also
pointers back to other families where
that person is a spouse and so the one
set of pointers the child to family
pointers point up the tree and the
others supposed to family point down and
then families I have pointers to the
husband and wife and also to the
children and they also have in them
other properties as we saw such as
marriage as the date of the marriage
ceremony and things like that one thing
that I've done to keep the processing
relatively fast is that dates because
when they come in from the external
source can be in any format so i used
eight string or excuse me dateless to
take that string and get a date list
back and if i get a valid dateless back
then I put that inside of an
interpretation to use so that it
displays as what was originally in the
day
because I try to be faithful to that and
but i still have something i can compute
with which is the date list itself okay
so let's load the package and we can
look at some of the things that it can
do I've got functions that can read the
gedcom file we can read files off the
desktop or we can take them from the web
if you've got a URL and some utility
functions you know to test if a given
name is one of the trees that I've got
in memory the one thing that ancestry
can let you do you can build lots of
family trees in ancestry my wife has
about 16 of them that she's working on
but you can only look at one at a time
and they don't talk to each other but in
Wolfram language I can read in several
family trees and work with them
simultaneously that's what lets me glue
them together take them apart and things
like that or do comparisons between them
because I've got several memory they are
in memory and we don't pass them around
way we do traditional data objects in
Wolfram language if you have an array
you passed a whole array you're not
passing a name about it here we're
actually working with the names of
things because some of these trees can
get get very large and if you've got
them in a notebook in your notebooks you
know get very big and unwieldy so you
know we work with the names of them
instead and so we need something to set
the name for the current family tree so
let me read one in okay I read in this
file Anderson family tree and I gave it
the name Anderson I can get a summary of
it using the summarized family tree
function and here it gives a quick
summary the number of individuals and
number of families the number of sources
these are the sources in the source data
that came in with a file about you know
this person lived in 1910 at this street
they were the head of household that
came from the census so the census
reference is stored in the source and
that information about that residence
with the individual points to that
source citation so that's what that is
but from this information i can compute
the number of generations
and I can compute something like cousin
marriages so these are things that a
genealogist would be interested in that
are pretty easy to compute from the
graph structure itself so they're there
in the summary and then some information
about where the sort of where the data
came from this came from ancestry.com
family trees with the version 2010 point
3 etc okay um we can also draw a graph
and this is using the built-in function
graph all I do is assemble a list of
vertices which are the individuals and
the families and the edges and I've
color coded them here and put tooltips
on them so you can see who's what you
know who is where in the tree so this
this is Edward Anderson at the top of
our tree and here's the family he was in
and here's one son and here's another
son and so on we can work our way down
through the tree you can also see the
bar type bipartite structure because
we've got individuals at one level and
then families at a level individuals
families individuals families and so on
we've got functions for working with
individuals you can have more than one
John Smith in your tree my wife is Irish
but she has a million Thomas Mallory's
in her family not quite a million but
but several so yeah you can't just say
you know Thomas Mallory and get the one
person you're actually looking for so
I've written a function called find
individual that it very least takes the
surname and then returns all the
possible responses for that and you can
completely well acard it and find all
the individuals in your tree which in
this case is not bad and i'm using an
entity like object to represent them in
the notebook it makes it a little bit it
makes it a much more compact than the
raw individual object and it quickly
lets me know as a genealogist who I'm
dealing with I can tell the gender
quickly I've got the person's name I've
got their dates of birth and death and I
can easily look at this compare it to
another Gertrude ampere combi that I
might have and know if it's the same
person or not ok we can
in more detail about all the information
about a given individual by using the
show individual function their name
gender which tree there in the parents
siblings or spouses the children by each
spouse if this person have been married
more than once we'd have additional
entries over here for them and then the
list of the events that were in the data
as well okay and we can do a similar
thing with families okay so here are all
the families in the tree and we show
that the surnames of both spouses the
marriage date and the number of children
this helps disambiguate which one is
which and you know we can copy them and
paste them into functions for example
down here to actually work with them
okay and we can draw a more traditional
type of family one thing that I did not
try to bite off for this was trying to
draw a family tree like this with lots
of generations in it because that's a
hard problem especially the layout to
minimize crossings and things like that
and you know the the commercial software
doesn't always show you all of the
individuals they show you a subset
around the individual you're interested
in and they have some algorithm for that
and it's not perfect and and you know I
didn't want to bite that off so this
this much I can do easily and this is
one of the workhorses along with the
family tree graph function ok so the
algorithms I do make use of a lot of the
built-in functions for graph theory and
graph computation directed edges graph
undirected graphs so I can take a
directed acyclic graph and make it
undirected so i can do certain types of
computations on it edge counts vertex
counts and connected components are also
very important and if we have time for
all the applications which were probably
not we can see some of those here's the
family graph again I can get vertex
counts I can test if it's bipartite and
yes it is and it's directed and it is a
cyclic but it's not a tree okay it's not
a tree graph and that's
because there is not a unique route you
know I've got this person that could be
a rude that one this one this one this
one so that's why it's not a strict tree
okay ah let's see um there are a number
of different places I need to go with it
I started this work under version 7 of
Mathematica we didn't have associations
then we didn't have entities if i can
get a real entity type implementation
than i can do things like treat an
individual or a family as a function so
i can say you know use family as a
function and say give me the wife
property and it would then return
individual and for an individual I said
give me the birth property that we give
me the birth and another birth object i
could say give me the date or the place
and things like that I've got lots of
functions and a lot of them are things
like get children get death they get
descendants all of those can be replaced
with this idiom so this is where I want
to go next okay and I've got some some
graphics functions for drawing them okay
so I've got a few minutes left I want to
show you quickly some of the
applications let's see we can skip over
that ah ok we can do pedigrees so here's
that tree again and we're going to focus
here on George Anderson okay and we can
get his ancestors here and we can draw
them and so here we are here's George
and here are his ancestors each by
generation we can do a similar thing
with descendants and here's George and
now I've drawn it with the route to the
left so his descendants go to the right
ok family relationships this is some
real computing done on family trees so
here I'm going to show that tree again
okay so here's the trees as drawn an
ancestry and here's the graph is drawn
in Wolfram language okay here's George
and believe let's see George Where's
George here's George over here in the
tree okay we can actually compute
relationships okay so these two
individuals Bruce Johnson and Alice
Johnson Alice's the sister to Bruce and
we can do it the other way around and
find out that Bruce is the brother to
Alice okay and then we can also do
something which is I think really kind
of fun is we can look at all the
individuals in the tree and we can pick
yeah ok this one was it randomly picks
to individuals to start and it shows the
same person for both times and so let's
just pick another one here ok so it
shows the relationship in the tree and
it says that William Anderson is the
nephew of thomas anderson and you know
we can do all them i'd like to be able
to turn this around so i can click on
individual here and another one over
there and it will show them in the list
on the left and then tell me what they
are but it's got all of them in there so
i can find out first cousins twice
removed and things like that and if i
can deploy this to the cloud then when
i'm at a cocktail party and some he says
no she's your second cousin i can whip
this out and say no she's really my
first cousin and settle those arguments
with my wife she keeps us all in her
head i have to see it on paper okay um
we can also compute con consanguinity in
other words blood relationship how many
degrees are you related to somebody else
and four there are two kinds of that
there's civil law consanguinity and
common law consanguinity and they
compute it slightly differently but so
I've got both of those implemented and
so for these five individuals we can see
for example that Paul and Kristina here
our second degree related its lineal
direct relationship
and I'm also showing that one's the that
Christine is the granddaughter of Paul
in this case here Jane is a
fourth-degree related to Christina and
they're first cousins okay if there
isn't a common name for the relationship
I just say unknown okay and then we've
also got common law can tack on sale in
a tea and I won't show that table and
then oh this one's fun here okay um will
read in my family tree and we're going
to look at my grandfather it takes a
little bit to read this and i've got
almost 500 people in the tree deceased
people in the tree this is how i'm
getting close to the entity like
capability with the get property
function come on okay so a lot of
individuals looks like I've got a cousin
marriage and I have to look that up
because I don't remember it also you'll
notice now that we have more than one
family tree in memory it now tells me
which tree the individual is in to help
keep things straight so let's get a list
of all the places that he lived there
are 28 different residence entries in
the data I can use the geocode function
which is in the initialization package
for the notebook so it would be
available to you there we can go out to
google and get the coordinates the
latitude and longitude of each of these
locations that are a street address a
city possibly a county a state and the
country okay and here are a handful of
them drawn randomly from that set yeah
come on okay and we can map them so this
is one of the things I wanted to do okay
so here's the map of where my
grandfather lived we can zoom out to
give you the context it's here in
Buffalo New York in the eastern United
States and we can zoom back in now and
it's almost at the street level we can
see that this is where he was born in
1898 and that they lived there you're
about five years because there he was
present in the US and the new york state
census then they moved here in here over
here and then up to there then they went
way over here to Batavia New York and
then down to Easter roar and then they
move back to Buffalo in the Kenmore
neighborhood and then over here to
williamsville and this is where I first
knew them at their last house where they
live the last 30 or 40 years so you can
do some fun stuff like that with Wolfram
language which is really nice I'm out of
time I'm over by a minute I've also have
in here working with timelines taking
the same kind of data and producing a
timeline with a timeline function
ancestry starting to do something like
that but I don't think it's quite as
nice as what we can do here and of
course the data are all computable so
it's just a start to the fun things you
can do or the more serious things you
can do with the data and with that I
will thank you for your attention and
just catch me anytime this week if
you've got questions we don't have time
for them now so thank you